one of the things i loved about spiderman
no way home was that they were actual
supporting characters yes exactly versus
just fun cameos that's why i'm like it's
hard to believe a lot of this but a
lot of us just want to speculate on
absolutely i'm rooting for terence
howard to show up as iron man
what's happening there reject nation greg and
john here today no this is not a re-upload if
you caught our video from a couple weeks ago this
is a reshoot there was a copyright issue with the
last video and rather than just keeping that
video up that took a few hours to put together
uh we're like just screw it let's just reshoot it
you know you can't do that with a reaction because
it's a reaction but i was like no we could we have
the power to reshoot this and avoid that copyright
issue now most importantly and if you did happen
to catch the last one stick around because uh
we're gonna add a little bit more to this one as
opposed to that other one and we're gonna make
it even better than that one it's gonna be even
more efficient than that last one and what are we
talking about today guys dr strange ii multiverse
of madness cameos that have been rumored
speculated upon and just cameos in general that we
personally want to see ourselves and you know what
guys let's just dive right into it yet beautiful
bastards so the first thing i want to talk about
is something that i think has been rumored uh
ever since actually the announcement of disney
plus secret invasion show because i let a lot
of people are thinking oh my god does this mean
secret wars is on the brink of actually happening
and now with spider-man no way home out which
really solidified the multiverse being a very real
thing along with the loki series a lot of people
have been really hoping for secret wars which
if you guys don't know what that comic is it's
basically just a big collision of all kinds of
marvel glory in one from the multiverse and with
that people have been really speculating about the
illuminati possibly showing up here in dr strange
multiverse and madness now if you guys don't know
who the illuminati are they're a very important
group in the marvel comics comprised of different
leaders from several different groups to protect
earth they usually consist of namor black bolt
iron man or reed richards and dr strange and
so the hope that some people have been having is
that if the illuminati are featured in this movie
that they could perhaps be like a multiverse
gathering you know so instead of being one
dedicated to protect earth that they would protect
the multiverse and if you've seen wanda vision it
seems likely based off that post-credit scene
with wanda and the darkhold that she might end
up being not an ally to doctor strange as he hopes
in the trailer but perhaps an actual villain which
i think would be cool really see wanda maximuff
unleash that scarlet witch so with that in mind
a cameo or maybe a supporting character that has
been rumored to be in this since the days of wanda
vision how even one division came out paul bettany
was saying there's a special cameo that's going
to appear and then we all found out paul benny
was just trolling i was heavily theorizing and
i'm still sticking to this theory but now just
applying it to doctor strange multiverse amanda
that it's actually going to be patrick stewart
as uh professor x i think professor x could be
in here it could be a new professor x maybe
it could be james mcavoy we're hearing this
movie could possibly be really inspired from
the house of m which dealt with similar plot
points that we've seen set up from wanda vision
wanda wanting to maintain having her children
creating a new universe in that comics where her
children can exist a lot of timelines are being
rewritten and such but the main person they use
to help keep her in check or they or their hope
to keep her in check is professor xavier so i
feel like introducing professor x especially
now the fox merger is complete i think this
would be a great movie to introduce him in
yeah and i mean if the potential of the illuminati
also holds true i mean especially with cerebro i
could definitely imagine him piercing through the
multiversal void and maybe bringing that whole
team together you know and if he isn't here a hope
of mine would be that he has the uh levitating
yellow chair make it more comics accurate that
would be my main hope and of course you know with
this being multiverse of madness one of the first
things that i heard fans like really hope for
right when this movie was announced was getting
hugh jackman back as wolverine to make a cameo now
generally i've been on the side of he said goodbye
to that character we don't really need him to be
in here and i don't want them to rewrite anything
but it's hugh jackman you know and as much as i
want there to be a new wolverine for the marvel
cinematic universe obviously they will eventually
do that hugh jackman has been on record many times
saying how he's wanted to collab with the avengers
how is wolverine be included in the marvel
cinematic universe so just to give him that that
extra little cherry of acknowledgement if they do
throw him in here i'd actually be satisfied i've
gone back on that and so i don't actually think
he'll be in here but i would like him to be i'll
say that yeah when i think of all the places for
him to pop up this would be a prime place for him
to make an appearance in the mcu everyone cheers
and then we can move on yeah exactly and then
another one part of the x-men list uh there's two
more one is just a wish that i really have which
would be ian mckellen specifically you know
like michael fossbender would be cool but i
would i would root for ian mckellen to show up
as magneto here because you know one division
had a lot of fun with bringing us evan peters
as a ralph boner but the whole point of the fun
was that he's playing quicksilver that's at least
what we were thinking he was doing in that movie
quicksilver in the fox universe his dad is magneto
which lines up with the comics of house of m
so if there was like a variant of wanda that you
do see or she's hopping through another universe
where like her family her parents are alive
but her parents are not who they are in the mcu
it would actually be like her dad is magneto that
would be a great way to bring back ian mckellen
oh yeah like one last buy because you didn't
really get to have that true and i mean you know
as great as michael fossbender as i think if they
were to do that ian mckellen has that paternal
presence true to him true yeah absolutely and
then with like what we were just talking about
quicksilver as we saw in one division she was
really mourning the loss of her brother pietro as
much as she's looking for like her own children as
set up by the events of one division maybe she can
hop through the multiverse looking for quicksilver
to exist and then we'll get a ralph boner joke
yeah acknowledging fan outrages yeah i'm sure
by this point too you guys have heard this
rumor it's been going on for years i think and
the man the actor himself has even commentated
on it saying he's heard of the rumors regarding
him and how he hasn't gotten a call from marvel
and he's not the werewolf he's not the werewolf
either but he did say he would love to do it
and you know the big rumors about john krasinski
as mr fantastic popping up in this movie these
rumors are just as strong as they were when people
thought he was going to pop up in one division
we didn't learn our lessons yeah obviously the
fantastic four is already announced john watts
is working hard on that film right now and maybe
they already have a cast assembled like if we did
get a mr fantastic or reed richards in this film
maybe it could be john krasinski which would be
cool like oh we this is our introduction of the
new mr fantastic but you know after spider-man
no way home which did have that nostalgia blend
and if they are doing that thing where hey now
that we have the fox universe we're lining all
these multiverses called multiverse of madness
i would want it to be yo how do you say his name
johan griffith gosh he really should spell the
difference here that well she's screwing everybody
up the original guy to play mr fantastic from the
tim story films personally i know everyone's
really opting for john krasinski we don't even
know if mr fantastic will be in here but if any
of these rumors did happen to come true i would
love it to be young rufford i think it would be
nice to validate that and i think too it would be
less distracting like if you brought in krazynski
i feel like that's a post-credit scene move and
then this is one that i think fans have been just
demanding everywhere online i haven't even seen
a real rumor about it it's really just been a
major demand that i think a lot of fans have
been petitioning for which i personally after
hearing it went that would be the [ __ ] chris
evans as the human torch as you got freeway yeah
as you guys know chris evans was the human torch
in the tim story fantastic four movies and i
think that would just lend so much more credence
to the whole variant identity thing that they've
been doing within the marvel cinematic universe
and it would be such a cool way for chris edmonds
to return to the mcu without returning to the mcu
yeah and to create humor without making a cheap
joke out of it yes you could totally have doctor
strange be like wait a minute why do i recognize
you why do you look like steve rogers yeah yeah
yeah that would be really fun i mean i personally
would love to see that i mean would you guys
want to see that please that would be awesome
another one that i have written down here is
sue storm which makes sense you know considering
that we're talking about the fantastic four
if you have mr fantastic in here his relationship
associated with his just at least have zeus still
nobody else yeah it could be jessica albo which
would be neat there's been a lot more support for
her over the years that's the way it goes you
know justice for jessica justice for jessica
like knowledge the greatness of jessica film
performance it would be cool to see uh sue's storm
pop up in here because i think as much as those
films weren't exactly loved they were important
to a certain extent and sticking with the whole
x-men characters on this roster right now when
i first heard you know like fans asking for this
i i don't know about that but i i guess i could
i could see it he is in the mcu now officially
kevin feige has talked directly they are going
to be doing the follow-up to this film and it will
be r-rated ryan reynolds is deadpool we are doing
multiverse of madness i've always said that if we
are going to connect the universes i kind of feel
like deadpool would be one of the best gateways to
doing that he's the leader of the illuminati yeah
dr train just shows up it's just deadpool
yeah i'm just busting his balls the whole time
well i do think that deadpool because of his meta
nature can make the commentary on all this to
make the connective threads even better yeah you
know because at this point with all the there's
so many rumor cameos that i'm like man most of
these cannot be real if any yeah yeah they have
to be like blink and you'll miss it flashes or
something they won't be like character characters
but when you know when you're talking about
deadpool like i could see a possibility of
deadpool actually showing up in here well
yeah and think of how fun it would be to see
that character under sam raimi's direction too
because you could get some real army of darkness
kind of shiny vibes out of that and then sticking
within this fox universe one that i've seen a lot
of fans asking for especially after charlie cox
appeared in spider-man no way home spoiler alert
sorry about that ben affleck as daredevil and
i think it's due to the fact that the daredevil
director's cut has gone on a lot of praise even
for people who don't like that movie people have
been like but ben affleck's actually good in that
film he's had some negative association with his
portrayal as daredevil so this could just be
a fun thing to do for him same time i don't
believe he'll show up in here i really feel like
this guy just wants to step away from all this
yeah i i almost feel like it would take like
a really juicy role for him to actually take
on in like a decade yeah for him to come into a
place like the mcu yeah and then hearing about
speculation and rumors with variants of mcu
characters now this list is forever all right like
you can literally extrapolate all characterized
the amount of people i see on social media
just talking about this i hear this uh oh maybe
this or i would love to see this like the list
just goes on and on i'm only gonna stick to a few
that i i think would be like the most fun the ones
that i personally would want to see obviously
none of this is confirmed um but you know like
a popular one that's been going around for ages
because of the fact that we're dealing with
multiverse of madness this guy was originally the
one sought ad to play the title role the head of
the marvel cinematic universe tom cruise as iron
man there's been fan art of this guy for ages
so if we are gonna get various i doubt robert
downey jr would uh come back for this it really
seems like he wants to you know say goodbye leave
his peace with this yeah tom cruise is iron man
here's the honest to god truth i don't think he's
in it i don't believe he'd do it for some reason
i just feel like he he wouldn't however i would
love to be wrong i would love to be wrong maybe
it'll be a less grossman moment where he really
wants to do it yeah that would be very gratifying
i think you'd be a blast yeah i think it'd be a
blast and another one with original casting uh
that you know when we're speaking of john
krasinski his wife emily blunt who was originally
sought to play black widow maybe she could show up
as black widow in this movie as well that could be
cool the reason why i have a hard time believing
this because i know we're going to do a lot of
multiverse hopping [ __ ] like are these cameos
going to be substantial whatsoever if there are
a gazillion cameos because i like a couple can
be one of the things i loved about spiderman no
way home was that they were actual supporting
characters yes exactly versus just fun cameos
that's why i'm like it's hard to believe a lot
of this but a lot of us just want to speculate on
absolutely i'm rooting for terence howard to show
up as iron man yes yes that would be very cool
absolutely it would be cool and it would bury a
long-standing hatchet i mean that would get people
cheering i think i mean then frick bring back like
edward north bring back and i feel like actually
that could work better because i feel like there's
a little bit more sort of latent love for that
movie but wouldn't it ruin canonically the whole
thing with the incredible hulk i think he is
because that movie is still considered yeah yeah
yeah exactly to bring up eric benner yes that
would be neat there we go show up because you look
at one movie yeah and it wasn't the same situation
as like all the things that edward norton has
talked publicly about of having his disagreements
with marvel it's just that woman eric banner
didn't pan out well but i thought it was good
yeah they were still figuring out the genre at
that point yes ever since the days of spider-man
we're always hearing rumors of spider-man popping
up here all of them it would be cool if you think
about it because of the fact that doctor strange
was in a multiverse spider-man movie it would
reason to stand that one of the spider-man could
possibly appear it's like tom holland wouldn't be
a surprise none at all i think andrew garfield
is one that has been the most beloved and the
most talked about since that movie that's they've
done a reshoot probably already but if spider-man
were to show up in here my personal desire would
be because of the fact that our director is sam
raimi that it would be toby maguire to show up in
here oh yeah like if they could get toby to come
back for this that could be more satisfying
for me in some ways more than spider-man no
way home because he's reunited with the director
oh yeah and what if he were to show up with the
person who has the doctor strange name in the sam
raimi spider-man universe oh yeah another strange
variant pay off that easter egg from 20 years ago
i've been ready to go that's dr schroeder that's
dr street yeah that's pretty good but it's taken
so one thing that i've i saw uh from comicbook.com
like ages ago a rumor about like loki sylvie and
mobius showing up here which i think would make a
lot of sense because of the fact that you know the
loki series dealt with the multiverse that ending
of loki which showed that the multiverse was going
into chaos one of these movies would finally know
so i think them showing up would make a lot of
sense another group that has been often speculated
about finally appearing this has been a group
that i've been hearing about for years now at
this point wanting them to appear and looking at
doctor strange multiverse and madness going down a
darker path would be the midnight suns bring out
that horror as much as i've heard the midnight
sun's talked about for ages introducing qualities
of them in here would make a lot of sense because
this is a supernatural horror it's like we've been
hearing talks of like i've been hearing about this
guy forever ghost writer you know this nick cage
version has been the agents of shield version
and now there's rumors about them looking for a
new ghost writer i actually think if they brought
ghost rider in i would love for them to keep
robbie reyes from agency because he was supposed
to have his own hulu show and then that guy can
and i'm like that poor son of a [ __ ] such a
good job let him have it yeah at least let him
get a fist pump moment in the movie and that
would make up for it for everybody that'd be
my desire yeah and then of course you know
as we heard mahershal lee has been cast as blade
he was in the post-credits scene for eternals so
you know the one wish that fans have been
having is for blade to pop up in this movie
and if blade did show up i think it would line
up really well it'd be a cool way to tease him
like i've been thinking that blake could
show up in moon nights oh yeah and if blade
is like making these little appearances before he
gets his official movie that'd be a great way of
reintroducing him yeah plus we could have ryan
reynolds make a blade three joke if debbie were
poor to be in the movie too perfect and then
another character that who's confirmed to be
in the the marvel's movie monica rambo is another
character that i is based off of her power set
i could definitely see her popping up in here and
considering yeah especially being in wanda vision
you know because the trailer does say i'm not
here about west view but i'm having a feeling
those of west view incidents are gonna really
factor in thinking about monica rambo possibly
would make a lot of sense and actually this next
one i've been thinking that she would appear in
here because of the fact that in the doctor
strange trailers you do see what looks like
schumacher some people have been thinking that
it could be a gargantos the tentacle monster
hp lovecraftian figure yes yes whatever that
character is obviously was in the what if series
so in this trailer we saw what i believe to be
strange supreme some are arguing that it might
not be him i think it is and that creature was
first teased in the captain carter episode of
what if and after the events of what if it would
make a lot of sense for me to get a captain carter
to appear in this video yeah absolutely and i
mean you know we've seen doctor strange obviously
recruiting other people's help throughout the
trailer and if they are going to actually start
tying in the events of what if i think that
could actually be really cool and it could
help that episode kind of appreciate in value for
people i think this is kind of just an obvious
one obviously it's not confirmed but of all the
characters to possibly show up yeah like i haven't
even really seen rumors about this to be the
only prank with you just i kind of just assumed
because you hear their voices at the end of one
division tommy and billy wicken in speed perhaps
it might be a grown-up version people have been
wanting the young avengers to finally happen we
got kate bishop in the fold now so tommy and billy
being part of young avengers would make a lot of
sense so yeah i think tommy and billy could be in
here but yeah guys this is like the main ones that
really uh stood out to me look i'm telling you the
list goes like on and on and on and we there's the
ones that we just wanted to highlight ourselves
but guys who would you want most to appear in
doctor strange multiverse madness or anyone that
we didn't mention that you're like no it would
be cool if they feature them though put it down
below in the comics thanks so much for being here
and uh hopefully we don't run into any
issues with this one we'll see you guys